by the time we reach these we're just
like this
this one smells like a fraternity floor
oh I like that one very watery this is
fine it's kind of like fruity it's a
little bit like a pineapple juice taste
this one I just kind of want to chug it
and then flip cup it Tanya smells like a
police which is a sign is like a
sourness to it are we supposed to swish
it and spit it out for me this is scary
big scary beer what is it water Oh dark
beer I don't like chocolate it kind of
feels like bacon Oh - coffee yeah it's a
lot like coffee but it does the opposite
thing this is intriguing me which was
pretty good a little heavy probably an
oatmeal stout of some kind or a
chocolate stout I had oatmeal the other
day and it looks nothing like this
smells kind of like chestnuts or like
walnuts or something it smells like a
men's bathroom this is a different
flavor I'd be down for this this
definitely tastes like a really old beer
like an ancient beer is this a sea
urchin beer oh it does taste kind of
like the sea have in common
oh yeah this is college whose concert
beer it smells like a sticky floor I'm
smelling this and I'm getting like good
memories a little bitter huh that's
better
it's like beer pong dude this is like
mistakes but ones you don't regret the
more you drink the better it tastes I
know this is this is a pilsner it smells
like broth this is from the Czech
Republic I'm calling it man I really
hope that it's not those fragrant yeah
smoke like smells fruity and flowery all
at the same time I don't know what this
is it doesn't taste like any of the
other beers this one's one of my
favorites so far I know nothing but this
seems to be a higher quality beer the
more I drink it the more I like it yeah
but that's probably because you're
getting drunk
this isn't juicy beer please don't
describe anything is juicy everything
this one smells like a baseball game
they all kind of smell like me
oh this one's Mexican for sure like when
you know it'll taste good with a lime
it's generally right I like it it's
really interesting really nice this is
like weed I'm not mad at this one either
that doesn't sound like weed you walked
in and you smell that that would be
marijuana
smells like whoa cider dude this is
interesting this tastes a little like
wine it's a little bit stronger you can
tell this one tastes like that's dope
he's right I really like this one
actually this is like fruity is like an
API IPA hey what up Peru here during
Ireland we like bacon beer Indians you
gotta make your beer that's the one we
said we liked it feels like we've been
clubbing with our I did go clubbing with
this one yeah Argentina look the juicy
one here's his corona you thought I was
a pilsner right yeah it's as if
something has impaired my judgment they
have a lot of spices all right that was
the more flavorful Ireland I really knew
Guiness Guiness you're an old friend I
like beer it wins
Thank You JP er yeah world keep drinking
keep having fun baby face you really got
the birds
oh sorry they stink oh man I got a
deeper coming I'm Alaska no way I'm
gonna smoke give it to the Lord give it
to the Lord
oh it smells like salami